[Music]
Two and a Half Men was one of the
biggest hits in sitcom history but the
series finale was missing one of its
biggest stars for a very specific and
unique reason he didn't want to be
crushed to death by a piano so what did
Charlie Sheen want instead well to
understand the power struggle that led
to Sheen's absence from the series
finale first you have to understand the
decade of craziness that preceded it
when the show debuted on CBS in 2003 it
was an instant hit both Sheen and
co-star Jon Cryer were 80s icons
Reinventing themselves for a new
millennium and it worked Cryer told
Entertainment Weekly Charlie and I
really hit it off we had a great first
few years on that show it was incredibly
smooth we had a lovely time it was
working really well and then it suddenly
stopped working well as Sheen famously
and spectacularly went off the rails The
Tipping Point was reportedly Sheen's
2005 to force from Denise Richards
according to Cryer that's when Sheen
turned to drugs at first he could handle
it and he was still incredibly
professional and still Lovely by the way
to everybody on set but you could just
see that stuff was wearing on him it was
just the kind of trouble the show had
been hoping to avoid as Sheen had been a
tabloid regular in the 1990s Two and a
Half Men producer Chuck Laurie took a
chance on Sheen anyway writing the role
of Charlie Harper for Sheen but
following his divorce from Richards
Sheen began making headlines again for
all the wrong reasons he was accused of
hiring sex workers arrested on assault
charges and sentenced to rehab and anger
management among other things finally in
2011 during season 8 of Two and a Half
Men the show went on Hiatus so that
Sheen could deal with his problems
instead he refused to enter a facility
fired his private sobriety coach and
verbally attacked Laurie that was the
end Lori fired him and Sheen responded
with a typically unhinged statement
telling TMZ this is very good news they
continue to be in breach like so many
whales it is a big day of gladness at
the sober Valley Lodge because now I can
take all of the bazillions never have to
look at them again and I never have to
put on those silly shirts for as long as
this warlock exists in the terrestrial
Dimension Sheen wasn't exactly contrite
about his drug-fueled Antics in later
interviews either I don't know man I was
banging seven gram rocks and finishing
them because that's how I roll I have
one speed I have one gear go Two and a
Half Men survived Shin's departure by
killing off Charlie Harper and replacing
him with new character Walden Schmidt
played by Ashton Kutcher the show ran
several more seasons before ending in
2015 which is where the piano comes in
even though Charlie Harper was dead
producers hope to bring back Sheen for
the series finale the idea was that
Charlie would ring the doorbell then ran
to the camera about drug abuse and how
he was above all that then a piano would
fall from the sky killing him it would
be very meta and thus fit the humor of
the show however Sheen had something
totally different in mind he was willing
to appear in the finale but he wanted
his character's return to be a launching
pad for a proposed new spin-off series
called the Harpers which would have
reunited him with crier when the
producers didn't go for his idea he
refused to appear so instead The
Producers simply ran the scene anyway
only with a body double for the absent
Sheen and they added a coda where Lori
poked fun at both Sheen and himself as
well winning
it was weird end to Sheen's tenure on
Two and a Half Men but not the end of
his career or his personal growth in
2021 he told Yahoo entertainment that he
regretted how things went there was 55
different ways for me to handle that
situation and I chose number 56. and so
you know I think the growth for me post
meltdown or melt forward or melt
somewhere however you want to label it
it has to start with absolute ownership
of my role in all of it
[Music]
foreign
[Music]